Let's go next to our caller from the four
seven eight area code four seven eight. Who's
this where you're calling from?
Hey David, this is Spencer. I'm actually from
Colorado Springs for seven, eight in Georgia.
Isn't Colorado Springs one of the most conservative
places in the country?
Dude, let me tell you my life story.
I will. Please don't tell. I don't know how
old you are, but that could be a very long
story.
Okay. Okay. I'm 26 years old. I'm originally
born in Texas, but grew up in Georgia, obviously
very conservative area. And
Oh, you're talking about Colorado Springs?
I thought you said Colorado Springs, Colorado,
and then you went to Georgia. Oh, you did?
Yeah, no. Yeah. Okay. So then I moved from
Georgia to Dallas, Texas. And of course that's
very conservative, although fairly, I mean
there are a good number of younger kids due
to all the colleges down there. And so I'm,
I'm finally like my, uh, college fund runs
out. I want to run to somewhere more liberal
and more aligned with my views and a little
less humid, cause I'm a country kid and I
hate the sun. And I chose Colorado and it
turns out Colorado Springs. Yeah, it's the
most, I think it's in the top 10 most conservative,
uh, cities in the U S so I've made a very
weird choice.
Yeah. And I think that a lot of the, I don't
know if it's like the, the organizations that
sell disaster supplies, like, you know, 80
pounds of, of mashed potatoes or whatever,
but there's some industry that's really big
in Colorado Springs. It might be certain types
of ministries. I don't remember now.
It's the evangelical capital of the world.
Um, the Koch brothers resort, uh, here every
year. Um, yeah, it's full of right wing money.
Um, to get to my question, um, I've been a
huge foreign policy wonk over my, you know,
eight years or so being really politically
active and I, you know, always bring up the
military budget. I think it's $716 billion.
This works you not mistaken, but, um, how
would you go about cutting that in a way?
Like let's say Bernie Sanders gets elected,
how would you go about cutting that in a way
to not stir up public fear? Because the public
overwhelmingly supports the military obviously,
and I don't think the vast majority of Americans
can or understand like all the waste that
goes into the military. So what do you think
would be the right strategy or the right method
of going about removing some of that money
from the military budget and reallocating
it towards social programs or what happened?
Well, here's the thing. So the thing about
the military budget is with the military budget,
the debate is not usually can we cut it? It's
can we slow down the rate at which it's growing
and that's, we need to even restructure that
debate before we can even really talk about
cutting it. I think that there are two basic
ways that we could least controversially start
chipping away at it. One is there are all
sorts of programs that dictate the replacement
of all sorts of equipment on certain schedules,
which are just handouts to the military industrial
complex. Let's start to space those out, like
things that are replaced every five years,
maybe get replaced every eight, like that
alone is going to start shrinking. One piece
of that budget. And then the other thing is
let's actually start shutting down decommissioning
certain bases around the world.
I think that the last time I checked there,
we have like four dozen bases in Germany or
something like that. I think most Americans
would be reasonably satisfied that the u s
will be safe with only 25 bases in Germany,
for example. That's an opportunity, but we
can literally just start chopping things off.
And yes, there are people who work there,
we have to figure out do they lose their jobs
or do they get moved elsewhere? These are
things that have to be figured out. But if
you want to cut the budget, that's going to
come with the cutting of some jobs and we
have to accept that.
Yeah. I feel the same way about how people
in the healthcare insurance industry, you're
gonna have to find new work. Yup. Once they,
if it eventually comes to that. But one other
thing relating to that, what do you feel about
maybe tabbing military spending?
Yeah, I mean, anytime you talk about that,
so, sure. I have no personal opposition to
it. The problem is those are the types of
things that one party will say. We are, um,
uh, preemptively, uh, limiting ourselves without
knowing what the circumstances will be. So
like, I agree with you that we spend so much
already. It's hard to imagine any situation
where a capital actually in dangerous, uh,
but you will have someone who says, now we,
it's sort of like we shouldn't ever take anything
off the table. You're taking off the table
the possibility that in the future we might
need to do x, y, or Z. I don't agree with
that logic, but some politician will make
the case and then it will become an issue
of patriotism and the left will lose if that's
okay.
And like I said it earlier, that's my main
concern with the average American, their ability
to, you know, separate the facts of how much
we spend versus like where we spend them.
Yeah. But all right, I appreciate you taking
my call.
Oh, thanks for calling in. Yeah. Great to
hear from you. Appreciate it.